PROFESSOR: OK, why don't we
you get started again?
I can understand why there is
an air of excitement in the
room since tomorrow's
a holiday.
But we still got two hours
before the day is over.
Any questions on what we have
done up to this point?
No, that's good.
Let me erase some of this art
work then and ask why one
would indulge in this rather
bizarre exercise of taking the
elements of something that
represents a physical property
and constructing a surface
out of them.
Well, the name suggests that
maybe these surfaces, be they
hyperboloids of one or two
sheets or imaginary
ellipsoids, have something to
say about the property that
the tensor that formed the
coefficient of these
functions is doing.
So let me take the case
of an ellipsoid.
That would be the case
where all the
coefficients are positive.
And let's let this be
x1 and this x2.
And let me ask a
first question.
If this is to be a well deserved
function, does the
surface transform in exactly
the same way
as the tensor elements?
In other words, if we take the
tensor in one coordinate
system and then change the
coordinate system to a
different coordinate system, are
the coefficients in front
of x1, x2, and x3 still the
elements of the tensor in that
new coordinate system?
So let me show you that this
is, in fact, the case.
Suppose our original relation,
sticking to conductivity, is
that x sigma ij xi
xj equals 1.
And then for some reason or
another, we change axes.
So the new equation will be some
different coefficients.
Because as we change axes,
they're going to wink on and
off, still the same surface, but
now referred to different
axes xi prime and xj prime
still equal to 1.
And let me now use the reverse
transformation to put xi prime
in the terms of xi.
If we do that, we can say that
xi prime is cli x sub l prime.
That's the reverse
transformation.
So notice the inverted order
of the direction cosine
subscripts.
And then xj prime is going
to be equal to cmj
times x sub ep prime.
To find this, let's just
rearrange these terms in a
trivial fashion.
Then I will have cx sigma ij
cil cmj times xl prime xm
prime equals 1.
And what is this?
This is a summation of direction
cosines where the
first subscript goes with the
subscript on sigma prime.
What did I do wrong?
This is mj.
Why is that not coming first?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, what I would
like to get this in the form
of is a summation of sigma
ij prime over two dummy
indices l and m.
What did I do wrong?
Ah, yes, right, right, right,
right, this is li.
Thank you somebody said it.
And my nose was right in it.
And I didn't notice it.
OK, this is a summation of all
the original elements sigma ij
prime times dummy
indices l and m.
And this actually
is sigma ijn.
So it's the same set
of coefficients.
And that is a technicality,
which probably you wouldn't
want to worry about.
So anyway, the elements of the
tensor transform in the same
way that the equations for
the surfaces transform.
So if you change coordinate
system, the coefficients that
you should use should be the
elements that are in the
transform tensor.
OK, now I'm going to
ask a question.
Suppose I define some direction
by a set of
direction cosines li and I ask
the value of the radius of the
surface in that direction.
So this is some radius vector.
The radius vector will have
components, R1, R2, R3 or Ri.
And each of those components
will be equal to the magnitude
of R times the direction
cosines li.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: Could you briefly rego
over what you just stated
before you erased
it [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Oh, OK.
I'm sorry.
I said aij xi xj equals
1 is the original
equation for the quadric.
If we change the coordinate
system, we're going to have
some new elements aij prime
times xi prime xj prime.
Because we've got a new
coordinate system.
And therefore, the coefficients
in front of the
equation for the quadric
have to change.
And now what I did was to
express xi prime and xj prime
in terms of xi and xj using the
reverse transformation.
And xi prime in terms of the
original x's will be c sub l
sub i x sub l prime.
Usually, we write it xl
equals cil x sub l.
This is the reverse
transformation where the order
of the subscripts is reversed.
So this will give
me x of i prime.
The expression for x sub j prime
will be given by cmj x
sub j where m is
a dummy index.
And that's equal to 1.
And if I just rearrange this,
then I will have cli cmj times
aij prime equals
1 times xl xj.
And this is going
to be alx lxm.
And this will be alm times xl
xm equals 1, which is the
equation for the quadric in the
original coordinate system.
I think that was better when I
was standing in front of it so
you couldn't see it.
It's just that the surface
transforms formally to the
surface that we would create
if we used the new tensor
elements for the same change of
coordinates system, which
you would probably will be
willing to take my word for.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: This is a direction
cosine for the--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
right below.
PROFESSOR: Right below?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: cli cmj aij prime
xl xm, and then I collected
the cli cmj times alm.
And that is the transfer.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In the previous
[INAUDIBLE], you defined the
derivitave side as being
xi prime equals cil xl.
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: You can say that x
prime is cil times x sub l.
And if we want to use the same
direction cosine scheme but do
it in reverse, we would say that
x sub l is equal to c--
yeah, OK, x sub i is cli
times x sub i, right,
no, times x sub l--
is that right-- x sub l prime.
AUDIENCE: On the second line
to the third line, you say
that xi prime equals
cli [INAUDIBLE].
It's either xi equals xcli xl
prime or xi prime equals cil.
PROFESSOR: OK, you want to say
this. xi prime and cil becomes
xl, yes, yeah.
And then mj times x--
that's x sub m.
OK, and then this says that cil
cjm times aij prime should
be alm, right, OK, OK.
So it's OK then.
OK, that was supposed to be a
small point that everybody
would accept.
But now it's done correctly.
OK, let's get back to
this, which is more
hair raising and exciting.
What is the radius of the
quadric in a given direction
that we specify by three
direction cosines l1, l2, l3?
So there's some radius from the
center of the quadric out
to the surface in that
particular direction specified
by three direction cosines.
And we know what those three
components are, sub i, are
going to be in terms of the
direction cosines, magnitude
of R times li.
And those points at the terminus
of the radius vector
go to one point on the surface
of the quadric.
So these values of R are
coordinates that satisfy the
surface of the quadric.
So we can say that just
substitute Ri for the
different values xi in the
equation for the quadric.
And this says that sigma ij
magnitude of R times li, that
would correspond to x sub
i times magnitude of
R times l sub j.
That's the magnitude of xj.
That should be equal to 1.
And if I rearranged this
slightly, this says that the
magnitude of R squared is going
to be equal to 1 over
sigma ij times li lj.
So the radius of the quadric
gives me not the value of the
property in that direction.
This is the value of the
property that will occur in
the direction specified by
the direction cosines lj.
The radius of the quadric is
going to be equal to 1 over
the square root of
the value of the
property in that direction.
So this is why it's called the
representation quadric.
If you construct the surface
from the tensor elements, you
will have defined a quadratic
form, which has the property
that, as you go in different
directions look at the
distance out to the surface of
the quadric in that direction,
that that distance squared is
going to be equal to 1 over
the property in that direction
or, alternatively, the radius
is going to be 1 over the square
root of the value of
the property.
There is an enormous
implication here.
This says that the value of the
property, if the quadratic
form is an ellipsoid, the value
of the property as we go
around in different directions
in the crystal is going to be
a smooth, uniformly
varying function.
They're going to be no
lobes sticking out.
dimples, no lumps.
It's going to be an almost
monotonous property, not very
interesting.
It's going to change
in a uniform way.
And in fact, we could put the
two surfaces side by side.
If this is the value of the
quadric as a function of
direction, if we make a polar
plot of the property as a
function of direction, it's
going to look sort of like the
reciprocal of this.
The minimum value of the
property will be in the
direction of the maximum value
of the radius of the quadric.
And the maximum value of the
property is going to go in the
direction of the
minimum value.
So the value of the property as
a function of direction is
going to be a quasi-ellipsoidal
sort of
variation but not really
an ellipsoid.
It's going to go as this
inverse square of
the radii in ellipsoid.
But the thing is it's going to
be something that varies
uniformly between extreme values
of the maximum and
minimum value of the property.
We are, I assure you, for higher
ranked tensor property
going to look at some absolutely
wild surfaces with
surfaces that do have lobes and
extreme values and very,
very irregular variation of
properties with directions but
not for second ranked
tensor properties.
There will be a few variations
on this theme, which are also
interesting to touch upon.
In principle, we can get other
quadratic forms from the
tensor if some of the elements
of the tensor are negative.
And in particular, what
would we see--
and I'll draw this
relative to the
principal axes of the surface--
what would we see for an
hyperboloid of one sheet?
This is the sort of surface
that might result if one
principal value of the tensor
had a negative value.
Well, this is the quadric.
And this is a radius in one
particular direction.
What would this say about
the property?
Well, let me, to make it clear,
look at one of these
sections through the quadric
that our hyperbola.
In directions like this, we
have a radius that is a
minimum out to the surface.
In other directions,
the radius gets
progressively larger.
And then if we plot the
reciprocal of the square root
of that, that says that, in
this direction, we get the
maximum value of the property.
And as the direction approaches
the asymptote, the
reciprocal will go down to 0.
But how did I get
two y-axes here?
OK, so the maximum will
be in the direction
of the minimum radius.
And then it will go down
to 0 for the asymptote.
And that's going to be
symmetrical on either side of
this principle axis.
So what then are the radii in
directions outside of the
asymptotes of this
hyperboloid?
Within this range, the
radius is imaginary.
But if you square it, you
get a negative number.
So within these two lobes,
the value of
the property is positive.
As you go away from the
asymptotes, you'll get another
lobe like this and another lobe
like this where the value
of the property is negative.
How in the world could
you get anything
that looked like that?
Well, a good example of a
property that has this
behavior is thermal expansion.
And let me give you
two examples.
The structure of selenium
and tellurium
is a hexagonal structure.
And there are chain-like
molecules that are pairs of
bonds that rise up around
a threefold screw axis.
So this is two coordinated atoms
in the structure just
spirals up in this triangular
spiral around the threefold
screw axis.
So this is a material in which
the bonding is very, very
anisotropic.
The bonding within these
covalently bonded spirals,
which are like springs that you
might put on your screen
door in the summertime, the
bonding is very strong.
Between these individual
molecular chains, the bonding
is very weak.
So what happens when you
heat this stuff up?
It expands like the dickens
in the direction
of these weak bonds.
But the spirals are, in part,
held in this extended form by
repulsive interactions
in like chains.
So when these spirals move apart
as a result of large
thermal expansion in the plane
normal to the chain, the
chains relax a little bit.
So you have a large positive
thermal expansion here.
But in one direction along the
normal to the hexagonal in the
structure, the thermal expansion
is negative.
And that gives you a variation
of property with direction
that looks exactly like this.
Negative value of the property,
that means the
structure, contracts
in that direction,
positive values this way.
The structure expands.
So there's a good
example of this.
There's another example of a
material, which, again, has a
negative thermal expansion
in one direction.
And this is calcium carbonate,
which is a complicated
hexagonal structure.
But it looks very, very much
like the structure of rock
salt in a distorted form.
These are the calcium atoms.
And calcite is CaCL3 And
the calciums are in a
face-centered cubic
arrangement just
like in rock salt.
The carbonate groups are very
tightly bonded little
triangles with the carbon
in the middle.
And these things are arranged
on the edges of the cell.
And this is going to
be very schematic.
These triangles are
normal to the body
diagonal of the cells.
So you have one family of
triangles that are all
parallel to one another.
On the next edge, the triangles
are anti-parallel to
this first orientation.
So think of rock salt.
Tip it up on its
body diagonal.
Every place you have a chlorine
anion, place a
triangle in an orientation that
is perpendicular to the
body's diagonal of the
rock salt structure.
Again, these tightly bonded
little triangles don't do much
as you increase temperature.
But the bonding between the
calcium and the triangles is
rather weak.
So again, you find that the
structure expands in one
direction so strongly that
it contracts to the other
direction so calcium
carbonate.
The calcite form also has the
distinction of having a
negative thermal expansion
coefficient.
We'll talk quite a bit about
expansion coefficients as one
example of a tensor property.
Interestingly, and we'll say
more about this and I'll give
you some references when we come
to this point, can you
get a material that has a
negative thermal expansion
coefficient in all directions?
No, that seems as though it
would violate in a flagrant
way some vast law of
thermodynamics that things
have to increase their volume
when you increase temperature.
There were, however, a few odd
ball materials that over a
very, very limited temperature
range would contract but only
by a tiny amount in
all directions.
And then one of the very
interesting discoveries of
recent years done primarily by
a crystal chemist named Art
Slate, who's out at the
University of Oregon, he
discovered a family of materials
that have large
negative expansion coefficients
in all directions
over a considerable range of
temperatures, like 100 degrees.
So these are materials, when
you heat them up, they
contract amazing
as that seems.
And there's a structural
reason for it.
These are tetrahedral frameworks
in which one corner
of a tetrahedron is dangling.
And as you heat it up, this
tetrahedral corner can get
closer to other tetrahedra,
which takes energy to do.
But in so doing, you actually
are changing the net volume
occupied by the solid
so very, very
anomalous set of compounds.
More of these have been found.
There are probably a dozen
materials now that have
negative thermal expansion
coefficients in all
directions.
So is the imaginary ellipsoid
a viable representation
quadric for real materials?
Yes, in the case of thermal
expansion coefficients.
OK, so the representation
quadric then is a dandy device
for seeing with one function
how a property
will vary with direction.
For an ellipsodial quadric, the
variation of the property
itself with direction is not
really ellipsodial but
quasi-ellipsodial in that
there's a small principal
axis, a large principal axis.
And the large value of the
property goes with the short
axis of the quadric.
So we have a nice device for
representing the value of the
property as a function
of direction.
It looks as though we've lost
all information about the
direction of the resulting
vector, the generalized
displacement.
It looks as though that's
not in here at all.
Well, there was an ad years
ago for a bottle spaghetti
sauce, which offends many cooks
who are very fiercely
proud of their own
spaghetti sauce.
So here's a wife who's using
the canned stuff.
And her husband comes home and
looks at it very, very
skeptically and says,
where's the basil?
And the housewife says,
it's in there.
It's in there.
And he sniffs again and says,
where is the basil?
And she says finally,
it's in there.
It's in there.
Well, this is a similar
situation.
Where is the direction of
the generalized force?
And I say, it's in there.
It's in there.
Not obvious, but
it's in there.
So let me now show you
where it is lurking.
I think we have time to
carry this through.
Let me describe how it's
embodied in the quadric and
then prove to you that this
is indeed the case.
And I'll use a general quadric
in the form of an ellipsoid.
That looks more like an
egg than an ellipsoid.
It has a pointed end.
OK, this is something
that's called the
radius normal property.
And what it says, in words, is
that, if you pick a particular
direction relative to the
quadric, we know that its
length is going to be inversely
proportional to the
square root of the value
of the property.
If you want to know what the
direction of the resulting
vector is, for example, in our
relation for conductivity now
getting very warm, it says the
current flow is given by a
linear combination of
every component of
the electric field.
The radius normal properties is
that, if you want to know
where J is for this particular
direction, look at the point
where the radius vector
intersects the surface of the
quadric and, at that point,
construct a perpendicular to
the surface, which, in general,
will not be parallel
to R. And this will be the
direction of J. It won't give
you the magnitude.
But it'll give you the
direction of it.
OK, let me now prove to you
that the quadric does have
this property.
In our conductivity relation,
the direction of J is going to
be given by the tensor
relation.
Namely that J sub i is equal
to sigma ij times E sub j,
which can be written as sigma ij
times the direction cosines
of E sub j times the
magnitude of E.
I'm going to want to compare
this expression, with which
you're very familiar term by
term, with the normal to the
surface that we can
compute from its
derivative at that point.
So this will say that J1 is
equal to sigma 1, 1 l1 times
the magnitude of E plus sigma
1, 2 times l2 times the
magnitude of E plus sigma 1, 3
times l3 times the magnitude
of E. And I don't need
to write much more.
J2 will be sigma 2, 1 times l1
magnitude of E plus sigma 2, 2
l2 times the magnitude
of E and so on.
What is going to be the normal
to the surface as a function
of direction?
OK, to do this I'm going to
say that the normal to the
surface is going to be, if I
have some function of xyz, the
normal to that function
is the gradient.
Let me say that that's
G of xyz.
And we can say then that the x1
component of the normal is
not going to be equal to but
proportional to the gradient
of the equation for the quadric
with respect to x1,
dx2, and dx3.
So it's going to be proportional
to the
differential of the function
that gives us the surface with
respect to x1 times i plus the
differential of the function
with respect to x2 times
j plus dF dx3 times k.
So this is the normal
entirely.
So if we split this into
components, N1 is going to be
equal to dF dx1.
And if I differentiate the
equation for the quadric,
that's going to be 2 sigma
1, 1 times x1.
Remember the equation for the
quadrant is sigma 1, 1 times
x1 squared plus sigma
1, 2 times x1 x2.
So if I differentiate--
let me write it down.
If I take those terms and
differentiate with respect to
x1, I'm going to get 2
sigma 1, 1 times x1.
Here I'll get sigma
1, 2 times x2.
But then down in this line where
I have a sigma 2, 1 x2
x1, if I differentiate with
respect to x1, I'll have
another term sigma 2, 1.
And if I differentiate with
respect to x3, I'll have sigma
1, 3 plus sigma 3, 1 times x3.
And a similar thing for the x2
component of the normal,
that's going to be proportional
to the gradient
with respect to x2.
And that's going to be equal to
sigma 1, 2 plus sigma 2, 1
times x1 plus 2 sigma 2, 2 times
x2 plus sigma 2, 3 plus
sigma 3, 2 times x3 and
similarly for N3.
OK, I've made my case if I
can demonstrate that each
component of J, J sub i, is
proportional to each component
of the gradient to the function
that defines the quadric.
If you look at them, they're
close but no cigar.
The first term is OK.
I've got a 2 out in front of
sigma 1, 1 for the x1 term.
Here, though, I have the sum
of two off-diagonal terms.
And for this expression,
I have just sigma 1, 2.
And down here I've just the
single term sigma 2, 1.
So the conclusion we're forced
to draw is that these two
expressions would have
components of a vector that
are parallel to one another
if sigma 1, 2 was
equal to sigma 2, 1.
Because if these were equal,
I could write just
twice sigma 1, 2.
And down here I could write
twice sigma 2, 1 and do that
all the way through these
two expressions.
And then this factor of 2 would
just be part of the
proportionality constant.
So the radius normal property
will be true or valid only for
symmetric tensors.
That is it's going to be true
only if sigma ij is
equal to sigma ji.
We mentioned when we first
started talking about second
ranked tensors that a tensor
does not have to be symmetric.
And showing that the tensor is
symmetric has nothing to do
with symmetry.
Because it's symmetric in an
algebraic sense not in the
literal sense of geometrical
symmetry.
And there are some properties,
the thermal electricity tensor
is one notable example, where
the tensor is a second ranked
tensor but it decidedly
is not symmetric.
So this is OK for most
properties but not all.
OK, so here are properties of
the representation surface
that we can construct from the
representation quadric.
And what I would like to do
following this and after the
inevitable unpleasantness of
a quiz is to look at some
specific properties that
illustrate second ranked
tensor properties.
And in particular, I would like
to look at some other
sorts of second ranked tensor
properties that represent
generalized forces, namely
stress and strain.
You've seen these before in
other contexts perhaps not
actually defined rigorously
in terms of tensors.
Because, obviously, stress and
strain can be regarded as
generalized forces.
A stress is something that
you can apply to a solid.
And that will cause various
things to happen.
In addition to mechanical
behavior, different properties
and effects can result.
So that is going to involve a
generalized force, which is a
second ranked tensor.
And a thing that might happen
could be a vector.
It could be another second
ranked tensor.
And this is going to introduce
us to the nasty world of
higher ranked tensor properties
and their
representation surfaces.
So this is a nice place to quit
and pause for a quiz.
When we resume, we'll look at
stress and strain in terms of
our tensor algebra.